I'm on my way to orlando in LA and I
want your suggestions on what i should
do there
[Music]
what's that believe nation hope you have
an amazing weekend so I wanted your
advice I want to hear from you i'm on my
way to orlando and then la in march one
orlando is for my annual disney trip
it's a tradition that we started a
number of years ago and we go over here
and i'll be documenting it and we have
one day off we've got shopping day God
Blue Jays baseball spring training dings
got three days at disney we've got one
day at Universal students into going to
the first time and I want to know what
do you guys think am I missing something
what is there must do in orlando so I
need to go check out if you're from
Orlando I want to give some comments
down there as well and then I'm coming
back to like three days to toronto and
i'm heading off to LA doing something
with 20 robbins and then Lewis house and
Brian Grazer in LA and I have half a day
after or before I have to figure out the
exact day if any you guys are in LA and
want to meet up let me know leave in the
comments they will configure to the
mound i can give you exact dates let me
sketch winter week when is my who's my
la de sol en la i have time in a 27th of
March either first thing in the morning
or in the late afternoon i think my last
meeting 63 so until you're certain
that's five or whatever i'll be i'll be
in beverly hills and what's Hollywood
around there sup here anywhere close and
you want to meet up let me know or if
you have suggestions of what I need to
go with food with la that I haven't
number four recommend I must check out
let me now live it down the comments and
hopefully I was getting a chance to do
it quick one this weekend few guys
hopefully you are having an amazing one
and it looks forward to seeing your
ideas listening to your feedback and
maybe meeting up with some of you thank
you guys for watching I believe in you
Oh continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see